legendary is here the new series follows
ballroom culture and it's different
houses as they compete in dance fashion
and voguing competitions to win a cash
prize
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now many were upset when the news broke
that Jameela Jamil and Megan Italian
would both be judges on the show shortly
after
jameelah took to her Twitter and came
out as queer and she is now further
explained the reasons behind the caster
this show is not supposed to be the
be-all and end-all Megan and I are here
to help get the show up the grounds that
loads of people see it and then as a
result of that people recognize this
culture and then start to center those
stars this is supposed to be similarly
to pose the beginning of what will
hopefully be a long way of loads of
different TV shows and films and stories
made about this community you need to
make sure that you're gonna have
eyeballs honest and therefore you need
people who have big followings and
unfortunately because of how our society
is set up the people with those live
followings are often sis privileged
people
jameelah also discussed why she was so
moved by those competing in the series
these people who living a lifestyle that
so much of our ignorant society shuns
and the fact that they are doing it as
boldly as loudly as colorfully as
possible is so empowering so few of us
can identify with that level of strength
and courage and ownership oneself and so
I think that it's very inspiring and
what was jameelah most looking forward
to seeing on the series 1 are the young
kids you might be queer or trans
themselves who haven't seen themselves
reflected back on mainstream television
being glamorized and glorified for i
think it's important for them to know
that like oh maybe not in my hometown
but somewhere there is a place for me
and there's a community for me where I
would be accepted
I said what I said and the other kind of
people I'm the keyboard seeing this a
the parents of kids who can be less
ignorant and more educational around
this community but also people who may
be feared to this culture will thought
there was something wrong but dirty your
shameful about it they can see the
beauty and the joy of it and you know I
think that a lot of ignorance and
bigotry just comes from fear of the
unknown and so let's get to know these
people you know we saw with Will & Grace
the difference that made to the way that
people are sought a lot of people
treated gay people you know there was
something about this harmless NBC comedy
that sort of humanized and normalized
gay people and I think that that's what
shows again like legendary and Poe's do
is that they humanize these people that
haven't been represented at all so are
you excited to watch legendary I am are
you still upset than Megan the stallion
and jameelah our judges on the show have
you seen the film Paris is burning it is
incredible and it really teaches you
about ballroom culture let me know in
the comments below
oh hey there if you want more LGBTQ news
and exclusive interviews click Subscribe
or watch these videos